all right Barbie Jean Barbie Jean uh
where'd you grow up where are you from
originally Lombard Illinois very
Suburbia lifestyle with a close unit
family of four
sounds like how I grew up right down the
street yeah Special tell me about your
uh your family
oh my mom and dad are this power couple
and uh I have a twin identical sister
and
you know we were
I don't know we were just this playset
everywhere of all of our friends wanted
to come to everyone else was getting
divorces and my family was so close and
so open and easy to talk to
we went to church every Sunday we're
very active in youth group and Outreach
and the community
um
yeah
so it sounds like a pretty great
childhood it was what kind of girl were
you in high school
high school was when I started getting a
little
well probably just confident I was a
cheerleader
I
started having sex and
also being a cheerleader I felt like I
was constantly sexualized being in my
tight mini skirt
being an attractive set of twins also
had its level of you know being
sexualized I would just see that glimmer
in people's eyes mostly men that would
just be thinking about having sex with
us or asking us if we've ever hooked up
with the same person always kind of
harassing in a different way you know
inquiring further about what we were
into
um but we did actually use that to our
Advantage One
one day
um which is a good story we
we were studying abroad together
and This MC it was like a bar or a club
and This MC it was having
um a pole dancing competition
and he was like you girls have to sign
up you have to sign up and you have to
be the twins
so we were like okay let's do it
we backstage
practiced a little bit you know got our
routine down we're like she went low
first and I went high and we swapped and
we had a little freestyle and then we
kissed at the end and that's the only
time we've ever kissed but of course the
crowd went wild it was wild there was no
question we won of course I mean
so I felt I felt good about that because
I was like okay I'm I was like sticking
it to all the men and all the people
that have
you know wanted that kinky twin fantasy
but I didn't want to give it to him then
so that felt good at that moment
and your family is sex something that's
treated as is not as something dirty
you guys are pretty open about it yeah I
mean of course like when I've had sex
for the first time it was you know I was
so young so I think my parents were
being very protective and
um but in my adult life it's always been
easy to talk about
um very open communication and I
remember the first time I my mom has a
bit of some boundaries like when I
started a dating couples when I moved to
LA she I told her I was going on a date
with a couple just naturally in
conversation she's like oh honey that's
too much information for me I was like
okay noted sorry Mom so you know there's
I know her boundaries and with my dad I
don't really talk about sex but all
right so you guys are pretty normal and
private about it all yeah I guess so but
so you you came to La when you were how
old
I was uh 25 20 yeah 25 from from the
Midwest I actually moved abroad I lived
in Australia for a year oh you did New
Zealand for a year
I had my first interaction with
a fetish in Australia for a job I
was struggling to get by and my friend
found this ad on Craigslist for a strong
able-bodied women to perform a fetish we
were like we're strong we could do this
and
he had a fetish for being piggybacked
literally just like wanted to be on our
backs
so we went to this yoga studio and uh
he stripped down
to his he was in a suit looking normal
businessman stripped down to his yoga
shorts comfy clothes we stripped down to
our bikinis
and I grabbed the camera it was all
videoed which of course had
anxiety and fear are hoping that this
video wouldn't surface one day and my
mom and dad wouldn't see it but I kind
of swallowed that fear my friend was
very open and fearless
so I just kind of took her lead and we
took turns piggybacking this man with
his hard [__] on my back the whole time
around the studio yeah he was on our
backs so we took turns
um videoing I felt good with my
photography skills I was getting good
angles you know we were having fun with
it
um it was definitely I mean my curiosity
too was exploding because I was like
how did this Kink happen like where did
this come from so as he was on my back I
I kept asking him you know where it all
came from and he said he grew up in
India and was carried around a lot as a
kid and just kind of realized that it
was something that turned him on
but he was so quiet and scared to share
with
his friends people he's dated he never
shared with any of his partners
so I just kept telling him like oh my
God there's so much more kinky or
weirder [__] in the world like just let
it out I'm sure someone would be into it
or just want to please you
so you know I think from that point
forward I always wanted to be more open
and just continuing to just inspire
people to be comfortable in their shoes
can you explored and kind of branched
out from where you
find
pleasure yeah
so well I went home when I lived in New
Zealand I went home with a woman for the
first time and so that primarily I was
just dating men
for I guess my eight years of sexual
experiences and so when I went home with
a woman I remember waking up the next
morning and there was just like this
beautiful sun like beating on her
soft body and I was like damn
I I love [__] but I also love [__] like
what I don't know I was very overwhelmed
by it because it felt so good and then
so
that kind of made me interested in
couples Group Play
so when I moved to LA it was the perfect
opportunity for me to dive into this
lifestyle because it's so I don't know
there's a lot of queer people here it's
easy to connect with like-minded people
I found FetLife which is a really good
kind of like Facebook for kinky people
you can post photos
you can you have a profile people can
comment and I just started meeting all
these
Doms I was dating some Doms in the BDSM
community
I met some
really cool just like fluid beings and
started going to sex parties every
weekend
so
I just kind of dove in and began
exploring with
um
impact play like floggers
I really
just love the fluidity of being with
multiple people at one time it was just
fun to be able to like go out with these
friends and then just end up in a naked
pile of bodies at the end of the night
I also loved like
sucking dicks with men too that only
happened a couple times but it was just
this really I don't know raw and
vulnerable experience
where I feel very fluid in my sexuality
so it was cool to share that with men
when that's just a little bit more taboo
I suppose when you say with men you mean
other men doing the same thing yeah like
sharing a [__] together with a guy I
feel like that was just like really
awesome for me I was like this is the
best I need more of this in my life
um but
then amongst the swinger lifestyle and
sex parties and uh
that kind of scene was also the BDSM
world
so they overlapped a little bit
um
but there were some sex dungeons in La
that I went to and frequented
met some really cool dominatrixes that
would
[__] me and that was just a blast and I
experienced was just like some fire and
just really started just I don't know
I've always loved exploring and it
sounds like you're very adventurous yeah
I would say your interest in general or
just sexually I am yeah uh I enjoyed
living abroad I loved you know I've been
skydiving a few times I've been bungee
jumping a few times I I love that
adrenaline high that you get and I think
with sex
it's almost
a similar feeling like an orgasm is just
I don't know it's very freeing it's very
liberating and
um the sensation I feel
I don't know it feels just as good as
jumping out of a plane to me in a way
um
I found that a lot of the experiences I
was
searching for all stemmed from kind of
like the sensations
I I really got into like
um slapping like face slapping because
the the tingle not like too hard I don't
love pain I'm not a I'm not into sadism
or masochism I don't enjoy bleeding or
being bruised but
you know floggers and feathers or just
um a slap like while I'm peeking and
about to orgasm I kind of channel that
sensation through my body and and it
just kind of explodes out of me more
powerful I don't know if that makes
sense it's almost like you have a very
wholesome
attitude about
sex but you're just a little more
adventurous than than
a lot of vanilla people might be yeah it
sounds like yeah I think that's a good
way to put it I think a lot of people do
have this kinky side to them and maybe
they're scared to let it show
um but I think there's a lot more people
that are interested in being more
adventurous or you know they're they're
tired of the mundane relationships or
after some time they just get bored
for me I think I've always even my first
love in high school
um he was my second partner but my first
real love you know I remember who bought
a vibrating [__] ring and I was like
this is awesome and I was like 17. you
know it was I think my my sexual
experiences just continuous continued to
get more fun and more kinky and they
still are
my partner installed this really nice
bar above our bed and it has all our
chains and ropes hanging from it so I
can't really remember the last time he
tied me up it's been a while but
sometimes I just like grabbing the chain
and feeling the coldness of the chain on
my skin or you know wrapping my hand
with a rope and just I don't know adding
these elements to me
are visually appealing but also like
sensationally it feels good
do you think there's anything in your
childhood that led you down this path or
is it just that you're adventurous yeah
yeah it's always instilled this
adventurous spirit in us you know they
always wanted us to is your is your twin
sister similarly in inclined she's not
as much
um but she did have a threesome before I
did which was so inspiring I was like
whoa this is my beautiful twin and I
couldn't believe it I was like what oh
my God this is so hot and it was I
watched it all happen I was there they
came onto her and it was amazing but
anyways yes we are both
I think a lot of my friends I surround
myself with
are very sexual
um in tune with our bodies and we love
talking about sex you know we've always
had this powerful Sisterhood Dynamic me
and my sister and I think we've kind of
I don't know just kind of use that
around us too to create really close
groups of friends to this day and
yeah we're always talking about sex I
mean anal sex
um
and just yeah oral sex I feel like I do
have an oral fixation I love having
things in my mouth so
oral sex for me is perhaps a kink I mean
anything can be a kink these days but uh
and then masturbation too is huge for me
and that maybe started when I was
younger I remember the first time I ever
masturbated it was like non-stop I
couldn't stop I stayed up all night
I didn't actually orgasm or anything but
I was just they couldn't stop touching
myself in my pajamas
um but now I love Mass reading on my way
to work I love masturbating while
watching TV I love
having a vibrator And my partner's like
dick in my mouth at the same time like
that's like my favorite thing
um or just having you know touching
myself while I'm getting penetrated
I love that I think it's I find it
refreshing to hear somebody speak so
casually and openly and
in such a straightforward way about
things that so many of us are
secretly thinking and feeling but we're
just too repressed to express it
I think we're I think we're all very
repressed we are actually yeah not all
yeah well thank you it's sad uh
I
even just
um
at my like jobs like I work at a
restaurant or I've worked in bars in the
past um
I casually kind of mention things with
my colleagues about you know this
awesome foursome I had or I'll share you
know
whatever it is
um and they're always like whoa like
Barbie you're so inspiring on judgment
and you look like you're so normal but
you're actually really kinky and you
have this other deviant side of you and
to me it's I think we all kind of have
it a little bit and I just like opening
people up to it because it's not weird
and it shouldn't be repressed I think
ultimately we should embrace whatever
feels good always how old are you 30.
you're 30. do you find you're getting a
little more you're pushing the
boundaries of of what you're interested
in or is it pretty much you're just
interested and that's it
changing so much
I just feel like it's more plateauing a
little bit I guess like it comes in
waves yeah because it's not like you're
going to eventually be into
state of masochism and
yeah like I've definitely figured out I
figured out my boundaries you know I
went through a phase
since I've been in La you know the last
five years or so
I dated a lot of
people that you know I was pushing my
boundaries or I realized once the
relationship ended like wait a minute
that wasn't that wasn't really
enjoyable for me or I didn't really
realize it and had to
um
you know figure it out figure it out in
hindsight so
I do think I'm
a non-monogamous person but I've been in
multiple
relationships where it was a
free-for-all you kind of just did
whatever the [__] you wanted and for me
that just from the from the beginning
like the first day you know I met this
guy at a sex party and we started dating
and it was just always
him [__] other girls on the side you
know I was doing whatever I wanted and
it was just very it was too much
um it gave me a lot of anxiety and we
were just building and like falling for
each other so
I figured out that you know if I ever
have a relationship we were falling for
each other but you're cheating
constantly well yeah exactly but with
consent you know I don't like to call it
cheating but yeah I've fallen for
somebody before I don't ever think about
anybody else right
well now my partner you know we were
pretty monogamous the first year or so
but we love to bring women into our
relationship so
I've never had sex with another dude
since we've been dating for three years
three and a half years or so
um and I'm pretty happy with that like
we've had a little bit of group play
with a guy but he gets to have other
girls but you don't get to have other
guys well I think one day I might want
that but for now I'm pretty happy I I
crave feminine touch mostly and so for
me it's it's a pleasure to have a woman
in our bedroom and that's what I want
right now
not to say that one day I won't want a
couple and we've and we've talked about
it maybe introducing a couple or
introducing a guy or you know I think
down the road maybe that will happen
but for now we kind of stick to just
kind of exploring together and
and it works for us I would think good
communication is key with these kind of
relationships it's it's huge I mean
that's ultimately what you need with any
relationship and that's what my parents
always told me too it was communication
and uh with him it's really easy
because he's so
he's just a no judgment Zone and so even
I remember when we kind of were in our
first year of dating I had a girl's
night went out with some girlfriends
with dancing
super sexy woman came up to me and she
just started swaying with me and like
our eyes locked and
she kissed me and I kissed her back I
wanted to kiss her but I felt so guilty
afterwards I was like oh my God Hunter's
not here you know what am I doing and I
called him from the bar sobbing I was
like baby I'm so sorry I kissed this
really sexy girl and he was like it's
okay it's okay like don't worry about it
enjoy yourself you know you're still
coming home to me right and I was like
yeah so it just kind of
you know I think it's okay to lean into
our sexual desires
I think as long as we're open about it
and communicate and and share then we'll
all be happier it's interesting how
different
the Dynamics are for your you you guys
as a couple to introduce other
women
that's all cool everyone's fine with
that but if you're Marching In all these
guys I think it might be a different
Dynamic it is and I've had that
conversation with him before because
it's different it feels different for
him too guys get very threatened by it
yeah the jealousy comes in swinging and
it's like whoa whoa whoa this is a
double standard like this isn't fair
um but I get it like I'm I'm the the
bisexual one I guess to put a label on
it and he's I mean sexuality's so fluid
but I would consider him more straight
um
so it makes sense I guess a little bit
like I understand his perspective but
it's also not fair it bothers me but I
think that's why baby steps are
important in all relationships I think
ultimately uh
you know if we just continue
respecting each other and being truthful
then
do whatever we want whatever in a big
city like Los Angeles or New York or
Chicago will have
enough of this kind of community that
you'll you could easily meet somebody
that's into the same kind of thing yeah
the community's huge I mean like I
mentioned before that fat life was a
great way for me to meet like-minded
people field is like a really great
dating app for couples I went through a
phase of you know really loving just
being with couples and being there like
plaything their unicorn for the night
um but yeah I mean there was like
WhatsApp groups now there's Discord
groups I mean Kik groups it's just like
once you meet people you're just kind of
and I guess it's maybe easier for me
being an attractive woman but
I feel like when I got here and just met
a few people it was like whoa all these
doors were just opening I could go to
any like sex party any weekend I wanted
or all these cool Dungeons and clubs
that were throwing all these awesome
parties and it was just like play time I
just always was like oh let's go play
you know and sometimes I wouldn't have
sex sometimes I would just enjoy myself
or watch I I think I guess on the topic
of fetishes that's another one I love to
be a warrior
exhibitionism too I love to be seen
um but I also just love
enjoying people and seeing what they're
into and my curiosity and my imagination
just runs wild
and having all these
interactions with people you that you
just met you may never see again does it
ever leave you just like empty or at the
end of the night you're like what am I
doing
yeah there's been moments I think
there's also been parties that haven't
felt as good as others
uh yeah and I remember questioning like
how these people were serving me and my
like I suppose my everyday life and if
they were connections
that yeah I guess were benefiting me
and I I continue to do that with just my
friendships I think it's good to analyze
all of your relationships but yeah of
course when some people are just after
sex I think it's hard not to
feel a little bit lonely in your
thoughts when you're like wait a minute
am I
pimping myself out or is this am I
disrespecting my body
But ultimately I kind of
realize that you just have to you know
you have to find the right people and it
all has to do with energy and I guess I
keep saying respect but it's just in
communication and I think once you find
those people that are
into it as much as you are I think also
now
I'm not going to sex parties every
weekend like that was maybe like the
younger me but
um you know we still enjoy
a little bit of Kink and a little bit of
play time
um so I think it's just also finding
that balance with where you are at in
life and
feeling pretty good is there any
chance that maybe you're replacing
the risk and the danger of of a real
romantic connection
with someone where you might get your
heart broken you might be disappointed
terribly
with all these little
interludes that are just like fun fun
distractions but it will never amount to
anything substantial
[Music]
previously when I think you could feel
very empty after a few weekends of that
yeah I think there was a phase where I
was a bit lost and I was
um at this time also dating like a
sadist so he was super into like beating
me and punishing me and so I think I
just didn't understand where my
boundaries were and I think I was doing
it so much you know that was my my
lifestyle essentially it was just
instead of going out to the bar I was
going to sex parties on the weekends and
so
yeah you're not wrong there's definitely
because when love hits you it's a
miracle right nothing else like it right
and having sex with a bunch of random
people every weekend or every week or
whatever is is not a replacement
yeah at least for me it was
yeah it wasn't
essentially what I enjoyed long term
but I do think it created this
energy within me that still is
flourishing with my partnership now and
I do feel like I found the love of my
life now and he welcomes like this side
of me
um and he wants to continue exploring
and growing our sexuality together and
so it feels
not everyone we're very we're very
cautious of what we bring in now I
there's also like crazy STIs and STDs
right now I don't know if you're aware
of this I'm not ever since covid like
people weren't going to the doctors and
people weren't getting their check-ins
because you know it just wasn't
as available
and there was just this huge like
Bloom of STDs and there were a few sex
parties that we were invited to but we
didn't go where you know it's just like
little ones where you can just take a
pill and it goes away but still it's
like you know you don't want it right so
it's it makes me a little bit more
cautious
and um picky and just aware that that's
out there but of course when you're
having sex you just have to be aware
that that's a possibility
just like when you have anal sex you
have to be aware maybe some poop will
come out
so
but
after all these
experiences you've had these Adventures
sexual Adventures what would you say is
the most important thing you've learned
about yourself about relationships about
love
good question
boundaries I think was a huge one
um you know there's been multiple times
where I've felt my boundaries were
crossed but maybe because of
some of those situations I wasn't really
able to
understand my own boundaries or even
voice them because
because I don't know why I didn't just I
didn't know or you know sometimes when
you're put in an uncomfortable situation
where you thought it would feel good but
then it doesn't
you get like numb
and you just kind of retreat so I think
for me I've been in some situations
which is sexual assault or
um just uncomfortable situations where
people didn't ask my consent before they
slapped me or before they did certain
things and it just
really made me realize that it's
important I mean I guess communication
too it's just important to to know your
boundaries and what and what you're
comfortable with and voice those to your
sexual partners to let them know and you
might not always know ahead of time
but I think as I've gotten older and the
more sex I've had and the more
experiences I've had I've realized that
it's
it's just really important to know those
limits and and welcome them and not be
afraid like just because this person is
able to
[__] a new person every week doesn't
mean that you have to be you know I
think I just like Dove head first into
this lifestyle and
now like in hindsight it's like okay
there's little bits and pieces of it
that I really want to use for the rest
of my life with my partnership but also
you know there's also ways to do it that
are
healthier for me or that feel make me
feel better did you ever feel like
you're being
disrespected or objectified
and you're just like something to be
used
I don't mean to be approved but it's
like you know sometimes it's just for
especially for a female you're just
you're there for you're there for one
thing nobody really
cares about your heart they're just
yeah it's more about the pleasure
um which is why I kind of call it
playtime
for me I guess I can
separate
sex as more of
um a pleasurable just so it just be for
the orgasm you know I'm I guess more
as a man in that way because I can just
have sex and not have like a connection
intimate or yeah a deep connection like
I can just want to [__] you because you
look good or you have this awesome
energy or like your shoes you know I
don't know that's that's a dumb example
but I guess you get you know what I mean
but yeah there has been
there have been times there was a there
was a time when I was at a party and
I was giving my friend a head and this
guy was behind me
and he was like coming up to like put
himself in me and my friend was like
whoa whoa whoa aren't you gonna ask her
permission first and I like looked back
and there was this guy standing there
that I didn't know
so yeah it's it's sad to think that some
people see me and want to use me as this
whole that they can penetrate but
and that ruined I mean I was the vibe
ruined ruined my vibe for the rest of
that night but
of course you're always going to meet
some people that are disrespectful and
that only see you as an object but I
think as long as I see myself as more
than that and I know what I'm signing up
for and why I'm here and why it feels
good and
you're just having some fun yeah I'm
just having fun ultimately exactly have
you ever had a
someone you've fallen in love with and
you just want to be with them and no one
else
yeah I mean I guess I was in a few a few
monogamous relationships before like in
college and in high school
um
it's hard for me to imagine because I
really love
women and female bodies and so
I don't know maybe I'll end up with a
woman someday but I'm pretty madly in
love with my current partner and he's a
male
I don't know I guess I like the fantasy
of having a core man and then also
having
um a woman so The Best of Both Worlds
yeah I guess I do want The Best of Both
Worlds but I also think
that maybe that'll go away I don't know
I don't know I guess I'm just open to
whatever feels good and as long as like
if my partner came to me tomorrow and
was like listen I don't wanna I don't
want us to be with other people then
yeah I'd probably say okay
like I love you so much yeah of course
but
I think with both of us
um
we both love it I mean who wouldn't
for him anyways who wouldn't love it you
got like these two beautiful women in
your bed
but it's usually I mean I'm the queen so
I remind him of that too you know it's
all about my pleasure this is about me
of course I care about your pleasure too
but
ultimately this is something that yeah
we want it together but
I'm curating the experience and I like
that he always treats me with respect
and always
um treats me as the queen that's
important yeah that's the key all right
Barbie Jean thank you so much for
sharing thank you I appreciate you thank
you very much